malaisie la plantation de j'adore
l'abysse exploitation de palmiers à
huile et d'hévéa et ses petites maisons
aux toits rouges sont les menaces ou
vivre les coulisses les ouvriers de la
plantation groupe est en colonie autour
de leur chef d'equipe ces charmants
curieux
toutes les plantations sont en escalier
c'est une façon d'utiliser tout le
terrain dès le matin et coulis travail
bien sûr et regarder comment ils s'y
prennent
ceci est un arbre caoutchouc il est là
il a été apportée voici moins d'un
siècle par un anglais qui au péril de sa
vie la volée en amazonie cette indienne
se prépare à bouger regardez le choix
avec lequel elle travaille
l'arbre seigner il va tout à l'heure
pleurer son latex
voilà qui tombera goutte à goutte
les petits récipients
exactement comme le pin des landes
le précieux liquide et ramassé bien
entendu et il est même transporté par
une femme soit et nous elles sont
courageuses et souriante
et sur le bord de la piste les ouvriers
se retrouvent pour collecter le latex
chaque récolte et peser immédiatement
emmagasiné pour être dirigés sur l'
usine de traitement toujours très
proches
pour l'instant on ramasse le latex et au
lopez
on dirait qu'ils ont des bidons de lait
il n'en est rien du tout c'est du
caoutchouc
au tableau le mans l'empêcher de se
durcir avant l avoir été vidée
il va tomber à côté vous allez voir une
panne aucun soin son père en sans doute
j'avais une quantité c'est pourtant
pénible à ramasser
il faut bien laver ses bidons pour les
emplir une nouvelle fois
vous avez assisté à une scène amusante
deux européens qui regarde travailler
des gens et vous allez loi une femme
voilà des femmes même elle défriche
c'est un travail difficile probablement
qu'elle supporte mieux le climat que ses
hommes en short blanc
l'atout même très chaud sans vêtements
semblent trempé de sueur et le voici à
l'usiné de la plantation où les ouvriers
surveille les machines de latex qui se
transforme ici en caoutchouc non pas les
machines mais le latex
là aussi les femmes travaillent
il faut être adroit de ses mains
c'est certainement une matière agréable
à travailler agréable à toucher c'est
joli ça à l'air confortable
voici prêt à partir cette fois
je fais ce jeune homme vous allez le
voir image va vous le dire
voilà
on a donc là
c'est une lourde frappe qui est chargé d
huile et qui tout à l'heure sera
transporté l usine par un camion après
broyage le soir un petit train de
couleur orange
ce qui est très gai transportera à la
gare les citernes plein d'huile
il est juché sur les hauteurs d'une
façon inquiétante
mais ne lui arrivera rien et voilà le
petit train
le travail est achevé mais rassurez-vous
les coolies n'ont pas perdu leur temps à
regarder ce qu'ils vont ramener chez eux
pour leur dîner s'ils sont très nombreux
et pour les paul gray de salaison s'ils
sont moins nombreux ce splendide sent
mauvais et envie à bien des amateurs
admirer cette maison
et extraordinaire de ligne et elle fâche
pour être une des plus belles de la
malaisie
c'est la maison des palmes vécu henry
fauconnier un français
et toutes ont à bord de cet avion la
province de choix mort pour gagner le
père ac nous nous trouverons une mine
détails que nous survolons actuellement
et là nous trouvons après le verre de
genre le bleu fondu les eaux et la
blancheur des sables c'est un univers
lunaire écrasée de chaleur
barrett canalisations et la s'extrait
l'ept
comment s'y prend ton d'une façon très
rafraîchissante vous allez le voir
voyez tous ces jets d'eau eh bien ils
sont braqués par un homme ils sont
extrêmement puissants et ils sont
braqués par un homme contre une paroi et
les eaux en ruisselant entraîne le métal
puis la boue obtenu est pompée mais tout
d'abord attendait de voir le gros plan
le voilà regardez-la opéré puis la
puissance vu j'ai sauté morceaux de
grands chantiers
tous avoir une petite pression de la
main
et cette vous êtes ensuite décanter dans
le long couloir mais vous êtes amenés
par ce périple aérien
et déversé dans ses couloirs ou
patiemment un homme remet hulot sait pas
si c'est très sain de marché dans de
l'étain du matin au soir
lui c'est son métier il accomplit
et
à force de décanter l'eau le métal
sortira il sera extrait vous allez le
voir le voit si on tirait du pussy de
charbon et il est mis en sac pour
l'exportation car il constitue une des
principales richesses de la république
de malaisie
et en descendant sur malacca on traverse
d'immenses rivière au milieu desquels on
aperçoit des pêcheurs malacca la seule
ville historique de malaisie ce sont les
maisons que vous venez de voir ses
buffles
et magnifique résidence thème celle ci
et il y a quatre cents ans saint
françois xavier va prêcher l'évangile sa
statue toute blanche domine la baie
malaga gardait toujours l'aspect de
l'ancienne colonie portugaise qu'elle
fut avec ses nombreuses églises sa place
et ses maisons rouges
on peut aussi visiter la région des
vieux fort si on va là bas faire du
tourisme gardait autrefois le détroit
vous voyez les églises saint pons fin
très sain et toutes ces maisons rouges
les unes à côté des autres
et
ces constructions plus anciennes
très ancienne celle ci et ses canons
maintenant silencieux a jamais espérons
canons tournés vers le large
et le coeur de malacca il est dans ce
sport encore animer les rues étroites et
bâché y conduisent nous sommes
et malacca au passé prestigieux a
maintenant le calme et quelques barques
de pêche restent la dernière activité de
ce port qui voit les boules gagner et
peu à peu le paralyser
hélène chagnon nous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de henry de
grandmaison et de solange prêtèrent
montage pierre michel rey script lucette
ambri sont claude génisson illustration
sonore dominic palladini